PROFESSOR: OK, time
for us to do one
example, a non-trivial
example, which
is the ionization of
hydrogen. It's a fun example,
and let's see how it goes.
So ionization of
hydrogen. Ionization
of hydrogen. Very good.
So we're going to think
of a hydrogen atom
on its ground state
sitting there,
and then you shine an
electromagnetic field,
and if the electromagnetic
field is sufficiently strong,
the electron is going
to be kicked out
by interacting, typically with
the electric field of the wave.
So the wave comes
in and interacts.
So we usually think of
this in terms of photons.
So we'll have a hydrogen
atom in its ground state.
And then you have
a harmonic e field,
and the electron
could get ejected.
So typically, you have a
photon in this incident.
We think of this in terms
of electromagnetism,
although our treatment
of electromagnetism
was not going to include
photons in our description.
But we physically
think of a photon
that this incident on
this-- here's a proton.
Here is the electron
going in circles,
and the photon comes
in, a photon gamma,
and it kicks the electron out.
So the photon has energy e
of the photon is h bar omega.
So when we think of
putting a light beam,
and we're going to
send many photos,
we have to think of each
photon, what it's doing--
whether the energy is very
big, whether the energy is
very small, and how does it
affect our approximation.
So half of the story of
doing such a calculation
is understanding when
it could be valid,
because we're going to
assume a series of things
in doing the calculation.
And the validity
still won't turn out
to be for a rather
wide range of values.
But we have to think about it.
So a couple of quantities
you'll want to consider
is that the energy of
the electron, energy
of the electron
that is ejected is
h bar squared k of the
electron that is ejected,
k squared over 2m
of the electron.
And it's going to be equal
to the energy of the photon
minus the ground state energy
of the electron in the hydrogen
atom.
So the hydrogen atom
here is energy equal 0.
Ground state is below 0.
So if you supply some energy,
the first part of the energy
has to be to get it
to energy 0, and then
to supply kinetic energy.
So the kinetic energy is the
energy of the photon minus
what this called
the Rydberg, or Ry.
The Rydberg is 13.6
eV with a plus sign.
And that's the magnitude
of the depth of the well.
The Rydberg is e squared over
2a0 or 2 times the Rydberg is e
squared over a0.
That's what was calculated,
and this is actually
equal to h bar c the constant
alpha times h bar c over a0.
remember, the constant alpha
was e squared over h bar c.
So those are some quantities.
OK.
So we need the electron
to be able to go out.
The energy of the photon must
be bigger than a Rydberg.
OK, so conditions for
our approximation.
One.
We're going to be using
our harmonic variation.
We said in our
harmonic variation,
Hamiltonian delta h was 2h
prime cosine of omega t,
and we want this h prime
to be simple enough.
We want to think of this photon
that is coming into the atom
as a plane wave,
something that doesn't
have big spatial
dependence in the atom.
It hits the whole atom as
with a uniform electric field.
The electric field
is changing in time.
It's going up and down, but
it's the same everywhere
in the atom.
So for that, we need that--
if you have a wave,
it has a wavelength,
if you have an atom
that is this big,
you would have the
different parts
of the atom are experiencing
different values
of the electric field
at the same time.
On the other hand, if the
wavelength is very big,
the atom is experiencing the
same spatially independent
electric field at
every instant of time.
It's just varying up and down,
but everywhere in the atom
is all the same.
So what we want for this is
that lambda of the photon
be much greater than a0.
So that-- 1.
So this means that the photon
has to have sufficiently long
wave, and you cannot
be too energetic.
If you're too energetic,
the photon wave length
is too little.
By the time it becomes
smaller than a0,
your approximation is not
going to be good enough.
You're going to have to
include the spatial dependence
of the wave everywhere.
It's going to make
it much harder.
So we want to see
what that means,
and in the interest of
time, I will tell you
with a little bit
of manipulation,
this shows that h
omega over a Rydberg
must be much smaller than
4 pi over alpha, which
is about 1,772.
So that that's a
condition for the energy.
The energy of the photon
cannot exceed that much.
And let's write it here.
So that's a good exercise
for you to do it.
You can see it also
in the notes just
manipulating the quantities.
And this actually says h omega
is much less than 23 keV.
OK, 23 keV is roughly
the energy of a photon
whose wavelength is a0.
That's a nice thing to know.
OK.
While this photon
cannot be too energetic,
it has to be somewhat
energetic as well,
because it has to
kick out the electron.
So at least, must be more
energy than a Rydberg.
But if it just has
a Rydberg energy,
it's just basically going
to take the electron out
to 0 energy, and then you're
going to have a problem.
People in the hydrogen atom
compute the bound state
spectrum, and they computer
the continuous spectrum
in the hydrogen
atom, in which you
calculate the plane waves of the
hydrogen atom, how they look.
They're not all that
simple, because they're
affected by the hydrogen atom.
They're very interesting
complicated solutions
for approximate plane waves in
the presence of the hydrogen
atom.
And we don't want
to get into that.
That's complicated.
We want to consider
cases where the electron,
once it escapes the proton,
it's basically a plane wave.
So that requires that
the energy of the photon
is not just a little bit
bigger than a Rydberg,
but it's much bigger a Rydberg.
And saw the electron,
the free electron
does not feel the Coulomb
field of the proton.
And it's really a plane wave.
So here, it's a point
where you decide,
and let's be
conventional and say
that 1 is much less than 10.
That's what we mean
by much less 1/10.
So with this
approximation, h omega
must be much bigger than 13.6.
So it should be
bigger than 140 eV.
That's 10 times that.
And it should be smaller,
much smaller and 23 keV,
so that's 2.3 keV.
So this is a range, and
we can expect our answer
to make sense.
If you want to do better,
you have to work harder.
You can do better.
People have done this
calculation better and better.
But you have to
work much harder.
I want to emphasize one
more thing that is maybe I
can leave you this an exercise.
So whenever you have a
photon in this range,
you can calculate the
k of the electrode,
and you can calculate how does
the k of the electron behave.
And you find that k of
the electron times a0
is in between 13 and
3 for these numbers.
When the energy of the photon
is between those values,
you can calculate the
momentum of the electron, k
of the electron.
I sometimes put an e to
remind us of the electron.
But I'll erase it.
I think it's not necessary.
And that's the range.
OK.
So we're preparing the grounds.
You see, this is our
typical additive.
We're given a problem,
a complicated problem,
and we take our
time to get started.
We just think when will it
be valid, what can we do.
And don't rush too much.
That's not the
attitude in an exam,
but when you're thinking about
the problem in general, yes,
it is the best attitude.
So let's describe what the
electric field is going to do.
That's the place
where we connect now
to an electric
field that is going
to produce the ionization.
So remember the perturbation
of the Hamiltonian,
now, it's going to be the
coupling of the system
to an electric field.
And this system
is our electrons.
So it's minus the electron
times the potential, electric
potential, scalar potential.
Now, needless to say,
actually, the electron
that is going to
be kicked out it's
going to be non-relativistic.
That's also kind
of obvious here.
You see h omega is 2.3 keV.
You subtract 13.6 eV.
Doesn't make any difference.
So that's the energy of the
emitted electron roughly,
and for that energy, that's much
smaller than 511 keV, which is
the rest mass of an electron.
So that electron is going
to be non-relativistic,
which is important, too,
because we're not trying
to do Dirac equation now.
So here is our
potential, and then we'll
write the electric field.
Let's see.
The electric field.
We will align it to the
z-axis to begin with.
2e0 cosine omega t times z hat.
These are conventions.
You see, we align
it along the z-axis,
and we say it has a
harmonic dependence.
That's the frequency.
That's the frequency of the
photons that we've been talking
about, and the intensity, again,
for these convention preference
will put 2e0 times
cosine omega t.
So some people say ep, which
is the peak e field is 2e0.
That's our convention.
Well, when you have an
electric field like that,
the electric field is
minus the gradient of phi,
and therefore, we
can take phi to be
equal to minus the electric
field as a function of time,
times z.
So if you take the gradient
minus the gradient,
you get the electric field.
And therefore, we have
to plug it all in here.
So this is plus e, e
of t, z, and this is e.
e of t has been given
2e0 cosine omega t.
And z, we can write
this r cosine theta.
In the usual description,
we have the z-axis
here, r, theta, and
the electric field
is going in the z direction.
So z's are cosine theta.
So I think I have all
my constants there.
So let's put it 2 e, e0,
r cos theta cos omega t,
and this is our
perturbation that we said
it's 2h prime cosine omega t.
That's harmonic perturbations
were defined that way.
So we read the value
of h prime as this one.
e e0 r cosine omega t.
No, r cosine theta.
OK.
We have our h prime.
So we have the
conditions of validity.
We have our h prime.
Two more things so that
we can really get started.
What is our initial state?
The initial state
is the wave function
of the electron, which is 1
over square root of pi a0 cubed
e to the minus r over a0.
That's our initial state.
What is our final state,
our momentum eigenstates
of the electron?
So you could call them psi,
or u sub k of the electron.
And it would be 1
over l to the 3/2, e
to the ik of the
electron times x.
These are our initial
and final states.
Remember, the plane waves had
to be normalized in a box.
So the box is back.
u is the wave function of
the plane wave electron.
And we could use a plane
wave, because the electron
is energetic enough.
And it has the box thing.
This is perfectly
well normalized.
If you square it,
the exponential
vanishes, because
it's a pure phase,
and you get 1 over l cubed.
The box has volume l cubed.
It's perfectly normalized.
This is all ready now
for our computation.